[Music]
the special councils Russia probe will
return next year but now it's the FBI
that's coming under mounting scrutiny
and for unexpected reasons this week FBI
deputy director Andrew McCabe went
before two House committees behind
closed doors for official grillings over
the Russia probe but it's the FBI's
handling of the Hillary Clinton email
scandal that's suddenly coming into
sharp focus congressman Matt gates joins
us from Florida with new information
about his Judiciary Committee meeting
with McCabe yesterday welcome
congressman so what happened behind
closed doors and what are you allowed to
say to us well Jesse this was the first
and what will be a series of
confidential interviews that we'll be
having with key witnesses that had a
front-row seat to the exoneration of
Hillary Clinton which seems to depart
from the standard practices and
procedures so I can't share with you the
specific questions or answers I can
share with you my reactions to them and
I could tell you three things that have
been confirmed for me first Hillary
Clinton absolutely got special treatment
her process departed from the standard
process most Americans would face second
she received that special treatment
because she was a candidate for
president no other reason third thing
that we absolutely know there were
people in the highest levels of this
government that were doing everything
possible to make sure that Hillary
Clinton did not face consequences some
of those very people have now migrated
over to the Muller probe and are
persecuting the president United States
without a valid basis and that's why the
work we're doing in the Judiciary
Committee is so important all right
that's very interesting so we all know
that Hillary got special treatment from
you know the tarmac meeting to writing
an exoneration letter before exonerating
her to softening the language to take
out the criminality - I mean she went in
for an interview and wasn't under oath
so we know that happened at this point
what are you gonna do about it well we
have to change the laws so that this can
never happen again we've also got to
find out whether or not some of the
bribes paid to the Clinton Foundation
are actively disrupting the policies and
priorities of the United States on a
going-forward basis and
we have a thorough investigation of the
potential bribes that the Clinton
Foundation took and then the actions
that fell as a consequence of those
bribes I fear that we won't truly know
the depth of the corruption in the last
administration but we've got to change
the laws so that never again can we have
a circumstance where someone gets
special treatment because of their
political status or because they're a
candidate for high office that is not
the blind Lady Justice that we promised
the American people in this country
under our Constitution Jessie I agree
with that a hundred percent so are you
calling for new or second special
counsel to investigate Hillary and the
foundation and all that well for five
months now Jessie over 20 members of the
Judiciary Committee have been calling
for a second special counsel to
investigate the Clinton Foundation the
Clinton email server and the entire
handling of that process but what's so
troubling to me is that the Attorney
General has been sitting on his hands
despite the fact that we've had these
calls for a second special counsel
the Attorney General hasn't done it and
it's just a double standard when you've
got this special counsel that has a
limitless budget limitless authority
persecuting the president and we're not
looking at the real crimes from the real
criminals okay so can I ask you I know
you're not allowed to say everything but
did you ask McCabe about that meeting
where it was the FBI agent who hated
Trump and his mistress they were in this
meeting and they talked about protecting
the country from a trump presidency and
taking out an insurance policy if Trump
was elected president did you ask about
that well Jessie I can't go into the
specific questions asked and the answer
is provided but I will say that when you
look at the commentary from the
mainstream media on that they're just
spinning because they have no idea how
to explain it but the American people
are listen I'm going to assume Susans
that you asked about that because that
is HUGE
I would assume that you did now this is
just breaking I don't know if you know
about it but it looks like James Baker
who was the top lawyer in the FBI was
just reassigned turns out they found he
had contact with this left-wing outfit
Mother Jones and David corn and two
weeks later after he had contact with
him
they break the dossier story seems
really suspicious yeah I don't
thing James Baker is a lawyer in this
fact pattern anymore I believe that mr.
Baker is a witness and because he's a
witness I think he very wet very well
maybe one of the next people called
before one of these committees
conducting a fact-based investigation
because certainly we've had at the very
highest levels of the FBI in the
Department of Justice a number of
contaminating events that erode the
American people's confidence in the
unbiased nature of these critical
institutions well it seems like the more
people investigate it's the Democrats
that look guilty of corruption not Trump
but we'll see you know anything could
happen in congressman Gates thanks for
your service thank you Jesse